[Music]
in funny gummies news Gomi Gomi okay
a nine-year-old accidentally shared her
grandpa's marijuana gummies with her
fifth grade class I heard marijuana
gummies [ __ ] you up yeah her it's strong
yeah I heard you just eat one foot of it
and they'll [ __ ] you up like the foot on
the bear the bear yeah
I was literally reading about the [ __ ]
cuz I've really been insomnia yeah so
like I've never smoked we've done
anything but I'm at a point now where I
need asleep and I heard that if I can
come to your house believe I am knock
you out real quick
you're too [ __ ] sweet to do that [ __ ]
and you have a baby to worry about she
would do it for you for you I think
she'd do it I've never heard that before
hit me in the [ __ ] face right now I
just come yeah but I heard so when you
sleep induced with like CBD or some [ __ ]
it's actually a really really deep sleep
well that's like some [ __ ] that idea if
you can't tell I got some huge bags
under my eyes lately like I haven't been
able to sleep like my Sami has been
killer right now so I'm thinking about
taking this ship but if you take edibles
and if it's processed by a liver like
the effect is substantially higher so
whenever you take edibles versus
actually inhaling and smoking it it's
two different things so that adjustable
is crazy like it's supposed to be insane
I'm scared so I'm a little worried about
that [ __ ] so I think was it was it Dean
like did they have like any medical
issues these kids no snap the host yeah
it was not the [ __ ] out they're all like
this cool I think it kind of sucks
though because like there are negative
effects to how like marijuana affects
children and like their brain
development if you give it to them that
early so that's like a huge worry oh
[ __ ] and kids ain't gummies full bears
at a time oh [ __ ] these guys were
[ __ ] high as a kite or hopefully the
taste they spit it out with a pupa there
are some students that went to the
school nurse saying that they felt sick
and they complained of dizziness but
they don't mention shooters are too
stupid to register it and that they were
giggly really kept laughing at every I
bet you they live high every day just
being a kid and the emotions and
everything that you go through there's
just 24/7 hi yeah this nine year old
girl she took it to school she thought
they were just candy and then she was
sharing with all her friends good kid
there's probably not that much though
it's not like they come into huge gummy
packs is there's only like a few in
there
ah that's so funny she stole grandpa's
like she just took it yeah I'm pretty
strongly confident say here yeah doesn't
get in trouble it's like a legal state
yeah in New Mexico so it's fine it is
legal there but and what a good kid
sharing the gummies I would have never
done it off yet really gonna have some
no you just don't put it out in public
you just eat it when they're not looking
you go on your backpack got it what are
you eating nothing just keep regular
technique pockets precious crazy fingers
already that's a very weird technique
yeah then you just put in the repaired
tongue and then just let the [ __ ]
Pringle somebody's [ __ ] know he's ever
try to eat a chip and keep it quiet this
is how you smash it with the roof of
your mouth on your tongue yeah you gotta
let it just soak it up too so it doesn't
crunch you put saliva on it no no what
I'm cuz I eat in class when you're just
like when a teacher is not looking oh
man they need to invent quiet chip bags
oh that's gotta [ __ ] it open up your
zippers hello loud when you chew on it
cuz I didn't likes next when I was at
what I wasn't a big sweets person I
didn't really like chips that much
either I just like food food like
burgers and burgers don't make noise
but it's also hard to eat a burger in
class you would big seller yeah and so
the school once they found out who was
the girl who brought it into the class
then they were able to trace it back to
the grandpa and found out that that's
how she obtained it and they just sent
out what she hide to her they said that
all the kids were sent home but that
they didn't have any lasting symptoms oh
you were gently she's away to home just
munched on a whole [ __ ] on a food splat
forever so the pants were like happy
[Laughter]
just clean itself is just a figment of
your imagination the first time I smoked
weed it was like schwag pretend oh ish
it was a quick shag it was like
low-quality week much stress viola we've
got five bucks and then you get a bunch
so I smoked that and then we went to
McDonald's and we just kept eating and
eating and I was like I don't feel high
I just feel hungry first time you never
know they kept getting me to smoke more
and I'm like I don't I don't feel
anything and then the first time I
smoked some chronic you're gonna say
crack for a little bit my friend's
brother had a car that he was working on
on the driveway so we just went in there
we hotbox that thing and we started
laughing for like hours like I just
couldn't stop laughing and I couldn't
control myself and then yet a grandma
that was on a shed a stroke so she was
on a wheelchair and then she had
grandma's in a wheelchair right she's
basically like looking at us from the
window livingroom window and then you
can see her going like that and I'll
that's like the whole time
I feel like oh my god crap on those were
high she's just screaming at the window
yeah because she had a stroke so she
can't speak oh but why was she screaming
though I don't know I was like that's
why I was so funny a lot of people all
scream like that so my friend when I
went to third stroke yeah I don't know
what happens but his ground he had a
screaming grandma all the time was
pretty scary you're just screaming it's
the only way they can communicate now
maybe that story had the weirdest image
I pictured this garage but you got with
somebody under the car fixing it well
you guys are plugging hotboxing this car
and I got it was pretty [ __ ] weird
dude we were like sitting in the car
like there was three of us and we were
just smoking and laughing our brains up
and it is grandma's just staring
directly at us and screaming at us you
know what's the funniest thing is cuz
because I've never smoked is when other
people will get high around me and this
is like the first time they ever smoked
and they're like dude this [ __ ] doesn't
affect me interacting [ __ ] weird I'm
like your highest [ __ ] bro but they keep
denying it constantly I'm not that was
your cousin you think upside down
drooling and they're so adamant about it
too it's like do this [ __ ] deceive a
[ __ ] learner
that's like drunk people I'm not drawing
this way I'm not drunk okay yeah and I
was always the sober already know just
observing everybody I'm like this is
interesting
I don't smoke that much anymore because
when I told you when you smoke when I
first started I think I was around 13
maybe or 14 ish but when I discovered it
I was like oh my god what damn no wonder
people do drugs really cuz for me was
the opposite I'm like who would ever
smell like this this feels gross like I
don't like this I think oh I loved it if
I felt like I was going into a different
dimension then I was like damn like
everything on weed is better like
remember that movie half-baked with
Divya yeah you know they're like have
you ever did this on weed like that's
really how old everything felt like
better with weed so I would smoke every
[ __ ] day and then it got to the point
where like I wouldn't get munchies
anymore
I just needed to smoke so I could go to
sleep or just Live Nation's
I didn't even feel normal unless I
smoked right and then I started getting
paranoid as [ __ ] every time I said oh
really
yeah it got to the point where I'm
smoking and I'm all like man the
government is watching who's and we
would be talking for hours about like
how the government's watching how we got
enemies and like we can't we got to
watch out because people might be your
friend or whatever and we're just like
yeah that's why we got to do this it's
like it's so it got really [ __ ] weird
right
this is like during the most
unsuccessful point of your life I was
like 14
you know what stupid one [ __ ] would the
government want a 15 right no but we're
like we're like seriously they're like
we might as well head [ __ ] foil on
our heads yeah but we're just in the
garage just talking like yeah man the
government they're out to get everybody
pot heads like that because I knew that
people like that too and I was younger
there all basement they're like you they
had to smoke to like live yeah I mean
you sit around like yeah man the
government's like the government's again
it's weird and they're like yeah Ron
Paul we're gonna do this Ron Paul yeah
and then like but they talk about it but
they don't do [ __ ] yeah I don't think I
have I don't have anything against like
specific drugs patient personally I just
don't like I think I have a fear of like
ass advocate right and the costly smoke
weed I have a fear of that kidding me
dependent on that to feel normal I just
want them to feel normal whenever and if
you want to take it recreationally
that's cool
you know but if you have to smoke in
every day to be feel normal that's weird
yeah but I had to take random piss tests
because I got caught for like a graffiti
so then my peel would like have me piss
and I'm like oh [ __ ] I got to stop
smoking weed because then I could go and
I could go to jail if I could it's like
conceptually for anything like
painkillers or you know that a lot of
people do take painkillers everyday just
because they feel like they need it
that's anything like tylenol or any type
of like caffeine like medication or
drugs like I just don't really like it
as much
well can addicted a [ __ ] to caffeine I
realized that even that's what already
much caffeine anymore
i cold turkey stop caffeine for like
three days and then I was like [ __ ] and
getting really like angry and antsy and
weird did you get those migraines I had
migraines no I didn't get the migrant
I've had those caffeine migraines before
but I was like man this is so weird I
was getting sad as hell and then I drank
a cup of coffee and I was like this is
great
life is a [ __ ] auto right now
she's trying not to drink coffee like in
that type of dose like caffeine so she's
only taking like matcha or something a
lot a little more mild but before cuz
she would drink my three cups of coffee
a day and she had to like we'd be on a
Saturday we have nothing to get done and
we're soon to jail she goes I'm like I
need a cup of coffee I'm like why it's a
[ __ ] Saturday not going to work and
she goes I need it I'm like not you're
not getting it it feels like you never
really woke up yeah or like it's weird
just chill out like yeah he's like on a
camping trip like every hour I seen with
a new cup I'm like you gotta calm down
yeah I did actually cuz it causes acid
reflux not a teacher like that okay if
you if you have a tendency for acid
reflux chocolate coffee all that [ __ ]
fatty food spice basically your [ __ ] me
you know so I had that when I was
pregnant horrible just drink a little
bit of apple cider vinegar
[Music]